the Chinese Prime Minister received a
warm welcome in Germany business is
booming between the two economic
powerhouses and German economics
Minister Philip hustla is encouraging
stronger ties Lee kichan spoke of a
special relationship and hinted that
special treatment for German companies
in some areas at a meeting with
university representatives the prime
minister predicted a bright future go
China still needs to develop the name
made in China Germany has already
established made in Germany as a mark of
quality together we could be a dream
team but there are wide-ranging
difficulties as well chance are
unlimited on brought up the sensitive
issue of human rights abuses in China a
music video by the influential artist Ai
Weiwei portrays the life of political
dissidents in China the German
government is emphasizing the critical
need to support human rights vivian
schmitt ina these issues won't be
resolved miraculously in a single round
of talks but it's important to bring
them up above each dish to see unlocking
vid despite some criticism the Prime
Minister's visit struck a positive note
so I know German relations are defined
by trade and that's better than ever
you